أحبك ، نعم ، لم أر هذا النوع
من النادل قبل أن أسافر من
جزيرة ستاتن على وجه التحديد لأتي إلى هنا حصانًا
مع الزلابية ولرؤية مفتاح الروبوت اللطيف
في أحد مطاعم بروكلين باهتة في
الصيف ، يقوم روبوت القط بتوصيل الطعام وإحضار أوامر تناول الطعام
ويساعد في جمع
لوحات قذرة جنبًا إلى جنب مع النوادل البشرية ، لقد قمت
بالفعل بمراجعة الدهون بالأمس في
Google ، وهو عميل تم تعيينه للجلوس في
الطابق العلوي ولا يمكنهم
الوصول إلى الروبوت ولم تكن سعيدة جدًا
به ، لقد حقق Robocat Bella نجاحًا كبيرًا
لدرجة أن المالك هو  التخطيط
لمطعم جديد بدون خوض بشري على
الإطلاق ، الروبوت لا يرفض مكالمتك أبدًا
وسيستمر في العمل حتى يغلق المتجر.
اختبار لمعرفة
مرحبًا ، كيف حالك صباح الخير ، كيف
تقوم بعمل جيد عندما يتعلق الأمر بأخذ
كبار السن من كبار السن دائمًا أفضل ما يمكنني
الحصول عليه لك اليوم لدينا محادثة  أنتم
يا رفاق
لكن الروبوت الذي تطنه في كل
مرة لا يستطيع فيها الروبوت تلقي الطلبات
لأن هذه ليست إحدى الوظائف
التي يمتلكها الروبوت
[موسيقى] ،
يمكنني توصيل الطعام بشكل أسرع من الروبوت
ولكن لا أعرف ما إذا كان  الروبوت يمكنه سماع عدد مرات
تشغيل أكثر مني ، وأعتقد أنني أبلي بلاءً
حسنًا مع ذلك
[تصفيق]
أنا أفضل نادل هنا
[موسيقى]
هل يمكنني الحصول على الشيك
، هذا صحيح ، لا يمكن لقط الروبوت هذا
الاستجابة لطلبات الشيك ولكن
يمكنه توصيله مرة واحدة  يقوم النادل
ببرمجة الوصول إلى طاولة معينة ، هل يمكننا
فقط إجراء فحص ، يرجى التأكد من
أننا نذهب ، شكرًا
لا أعتقد أن الروبوت يمكنه التنافس
معي الآن ولكن بعد 10 سنوات و 20 عامًا
أعتقد أن الروبوتات
تحل محل هذه المشكلة
أنا أفضل الخوض البشري
للتوصيات الخاصة بما يجب أن نأكله ، ولا
أعتقد أنني سأقول أن المرء أفضل
من الأفضل أن
تكون طريقة النادل الآلي
مثيرة للغاية من النوادل البشريين ،
آسف لا إهانة ولكن إذا اضطررت إلى اختيار
أي شيء عن تجربتي هنا
100 الزلابية